Transcriber: Hager Hussein
Gözden geçirme: Yiğit Yıldırım
Herkese merhabalar.
Ben Berkay Besler, milli
sporcu olarak
uzun yıllardır
motorsporlarında yarışıyorum.
Aynı zamanda mücadele ediyorum.
Öncelikle beni bu organizasyona davet
eden herkese çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Arkada görevli birçok insan var.
Hepsinin çok büyük emeği var.
Hepsine bu güzel organizasyondan
dolayı çok teşekkür ederim.
Konuşmaya başlamadan önce biraz
kendinden bahsetmek istiyorum.
Yarış hayatıma, yarış kariyerime
2005 yılında 25 Küçük Adam
projesi ile başladım.
Tabii ki daha öncesinde daha henüz
konuşmayı bile beceremiyor iken babamla
annem beni dört buçuk yaşında
karting aracına indirmişler.
Bursa'daki yarış pistinde sabah
akşam antrenman yapmışım.
Tek amacım.
Birkaç sene sonra bir dünya şampiyonu.
Yarışlar kazanmak, Avrupa şampiyonlukları
kazanmak ve en önemlisi,
türk bayrağını en üst noktada
dalgalandırmaktı.
Bu süreçte çok zor yarışlar geçirdim
aynı zamanda çok güzel
geçirdiğim yarışlar da oldu.
Benim,
şöyle söyleyim benim dönüm noktam,
2016 yılında Türkiye’yi temsilen katılmış
olduğum Dünya Karting Finalinde başladı.
O sene Belçika şampiyonu, Avrupa
Şampiyonu, Orta ve Doğu Avrupa Şampiyonu
olmanın vermiş olduğu bende bir
özgüven ve rahatlık vardı.
Yarış haftasonuna gittiğimde.
Kendimden çok eminim.
Çünkü birçok başarı elde etmiştim
ve yapabileceğimi, yani bütün emeklerinin
karşılığını verebileceğini
çok iyi biliyordum.
Dünya Karting Finallerinin şöyle
güzel bir özelliği var.
Yarış haftasonuna gittiğiniz zaman
bir kura çekimi yapılıyor.
Bu kura çekiminin sonucunda
size bir araç veriliyor.
Toplam olarak benim kategoride
74 tane sporcu vardı.
Bu demek oluyor ki aynı markanın vermiş
olduğu 74 tane araç ve
aynı zamanda
aynı markanın vermiş olduğu eşit
derecedeki hızdaki motorlar.
Herkes eşit şartlarda yarışıyordu.
Dolayısıyla burada biraz ön
plana çıkan pilottu.
Bir yarış hafta sonunda bir başarı
almak için en önemli nokta
çok iyi bir sıralama turu atmak.
Benim Dünya Karting Finallerinde,
ki sıralama turlarım gerçekten
çok iyi geçmemişti.
Yirminci sırada bitirmiştim yarışı.
Burada biraz tabi ki de,
büyük ihtimalle şey diyorsunuz;
74 pilot arasında yirminci olmuş.
Yani kötü bir sonuç değil.
Ama benim hedefim orada
yirminciliğe oynamak değil.
Şampiyonluklar kazanmak,
yarışlar kazanmak.
Dolayısıyla yarışı en üst
noktada bitirmekti.
Annem, babam, bütün ailem beni desteklemek
için İtalya'ya yarışı
izlemeye gelmişti.
Bir yarış haftasonu
ilk program, birkaç tane antrenman
seansı, sonrasında sıralama, eleme
yarışları, yarı final ve final
yarışı olmak üzere ilerliyor.
Sıralama turlarında sonra üç
tane eleme yarışı vardı.
Eleme yarışlarında çok iyi mücadele ederek
birincisinei10. ikincisini
5. sırada ve sonuncusunu
4. sırada bitirdim.
Eleme yarışlarının sonucunda, genel
klasmanda
5. sırada yer aldım.
Bu da demek oluyor ki yarı final yarısına
beşinci sıradan başlayacaktım.
O sene Belçika’da şampiyon olmuştum
ve aynı zamanda Belçika Şampiyonası’nda
ikinci olan takım arkadaşım da
aynı yarışta benle beraber yarışıyordu.
Tabi Belçika şampiyonasında
yarıştığım ve
onu geçtiğim için takım içerisinde
çok büyük sorunlar yaşamıştık.
Beni pek sevmezdi diyebilirim.
Yarı Finale başlarken.
Bütün hafta güneşli bir hava varken,
yarı final
yarısının öncesi inanılmaz bir yağmur
yağdı ve normal şartlarda, yağmurlu hava
şartlarında arabayı kullanmak
gerçekten çok zor.
Ve herhangi bir temas yaşadığınızda
arabayı kontrol etmek çok zor oluyor.
Yarı final yarışında başladıktan iki viraj
sonra Belçika şampiyonasını ikinci
bitiren takım arkadaşım bana temasta
bulundu ve beni pist dışına attı.
O an yarışın ve tüm haftasonunun, bütün
emeklerimin bir anda bittiğini düşündüm.
Ama tek bildiğim şey, damalı bayrağın
altına geçinceye kadar elimden gelenin en
iyisini yapacağımdı.
Bugüne kadar da hep bu şekilde yaptım.
Yağmurda gerçekten adam geçmek çok zor
bir iş ama ben çok iyi bir mücadele
ederek 34. sıraya düştüğüm
yarışın başlangıcına.
Yarışın sonunda 8.
olarak yarışı bitirdim.
Bu da demek oluyor ki
final yarışına 16. sıradan
başlayacaktım.
Yarış öncesinde annem ve babamla
bir görüşme yaptık.
Onlara dedim ki; yani bugüne kadar
gerçekten benim üzerimde çok büyük
emekleriniz var.
Maddi, manevi çok büyük desteğiniz oldu.
Ben bugün, yani sonucu ne olursa olsun
elinden gelenin en iyisini yapıp sizi
gururlandırmaya çalışacağım dedim.
Bir de motor sporlarında
şöyle bir acı bir olay var.
Siz bütün sezon boyunca 10 yarış 15 yarış
çok iyi bir performans gösterin.
Ne zaman bir yarış kötü geçirin, insanlar
sizi hemen sorgulamaya başlar, tüm
yeteneklerinizi sorgulamaya başlar.
Acaba siz bu iş için yeterli hıza sahip
sahip misiniz diye?
Benim hakkımda da bu tarz
konuşmalar gerçekleşti.
Ama ben bunu hiçbirini düşünmedim.
Şayet elimden gelenin en
iyisini yapacağım düşündüm.
Final yarışının başlangıcında
16. sıradan başladım.
Yarış içerisinde gerçekten çok iyi bir
emek sarf ederek yarışın son turuna kadar
mücadele verdim.
Son 3-4 tur kala 5.sıraya kadar yükseldim.
Bu süre zarfında gerçi bir inanılmaz
defans, mücadele,
her şeyi, bütün emeklerimi verdim.
Tek isteğim yarış sonunda
bir podyum yapmak.
Dünya Şampiyonası’nda iyi bir
noktada bitirmek istiyordum.
Son tura girdiğimde önümdeki ikili, yani
üçüncü ve dördüncü pilotun birbirlerine
çok yakın olduğunu ve üçüncülük
mücadelesi verdiğini gördüm.
Son tura girdiğimde içimden
geçen tek bir şey vardı.
Ben damalı bayrağı altından
geçinceye kadar
bütün elimden gelen
her şey ardına koyacağım.
Ama şurada bir üçüncü ile dördü ufak bir
temas yaşasa da
ben de kendime bir fırsat
yaratsam diye düşünüyordum.
Son 3-4 viraj kala önümdeki üçüncü
ve dördüncü pilot bir temas yaşadılar.
Ben gerçekten inanamamıştım.
Çünkü virajı döndükten sonra kendimi
üçüncü sırada buldum.
Bu demek oluyor ki kalan
2 virajda hiçbir hata yapmazsam Dünya
Karting Şampiyonası’nı üçüncü
sırada bitirecektim.
Son virajı döndükten sonra damalı bayrağın
altında geçerken sol tarafta
bulunan tribüne baktım.
Tribünde annem ve babam o yarışı üçüncü
bitirecek olmamın gururunu yaşıyordu.
İnanılmaz heyecanlanmıştım.
Ayaklarım, ellerim gerçekten
tutmuyor diyebilirdim.
Yarışı bitirdikten sonra bir ağırlık
kontrolüne giriyorsunuz.
Eğer araba aracınızla siz birlikte 165
kilonun üzerine çıkarsanız hiçbir
sıkıntı yok.
Ama 165 günün altın düşerseniz işte o
zaman yarıştan diskalifiye oluyorsunuz.
Tek kalan nokta ağırlık
kontrolden geçmekte.
Ağırlık kontrolünden geçtikten sonra
da yarışı üçüncü sırada bitirdiğim
garantilendi.
Podyumda çok mutluydum.
Çünkü annemin, babamın,
o güne kadar beni destekleyen,
beni eğiten birçok insanın vermiş olduğu
emeğin en iyi karşılığını vermiştim.
Bu fotoğrafta da beni podyumun üçüncü
sırasında olarak görebiliyorsunuz.
Dünya Karting Şampiyonası’nda
üçüncü sırada bitirdim.
Burada bir yarış pilotu olarak
size şunu söyleyebilirim.
Sadece yarışlarla alakalı değil, tüm
hayatta yapmanız gereken tek bir şey var.
Yaptığınız işi sonuna kadar, tüm emeğinizi
vererek yaparsanız isterseniz isteyen
herkes sizin hakkınızda kötü düşünsün.
Siz aklınıza koyduğunuz bir şeyi yapmak
istediğiniz zaman
size bunu gerçekleştirebiliyorsunuz.
Buradan size tek söylemek istediğim şey,
aklınıza koyduğunuz şeyi yapmak için
elinizden geleniniz ardına koymayan,
teşekkür ederim.